-Guys, it's time for "Tonight
Show Hashtags." Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag
and I ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
This week I sent out the hashtag
#LastMinuteCostume,
and I asked you guys to describe
your best last-minute
Halloween costume idea
in case people need one.
You know, it's coming up. Yeah.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic.
So thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#LastMinuteCostume tweets
from you guys.
Thank you so much for this.
Here we go.
First one's from
@ryanbartholomee. He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's a great one.
This one's from
@eddielovestoast.
Yeah, we've heard from him
before, yeah. He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Pretty good.
This one's from @minniyar.
They say...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Levels. Level.
This one's @haleyziomek.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Gingerbread man.
-Cute.
-This one's from @sammi051285.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Wow. That's rough.
This one's from @travishenry.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Nice.
-I like this one.
This one's from @dillonmthomas.
He says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Self-fulfilling costume.
That made me so happy.
Congratulations, Dillon.
This last one is
from @reneejordan78. She says...
There you have it, everybody.
Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.